venons en maintenant à notre feuilleton
et tout au long de la semaine nous
allons suivre une troupe de majorettes
d'hénin sur cojeul près d'arras elles
vont participer au 33e championnats de
france qui se tient près de chartres
entraînement intensif donc pour ses
pom-pom girls version française au
charme suranné
aujourd'hui nous faisons la connaissance
de la capitaine jennifer et de l'une de
ses élèves
océane neuf ans
le monde les 26 majorettes de hénin sur
cojeul sont en pleine répétition
dans quatre jours elles participeront au
championnat de france des majorettes
près de chartres
jennifer 24 ans est la capitaine des
frais ligne du cojeul savait qu'il vous
reste une seule répétition
vous avez bientôt du tout ce que j'ai
dit depuis le début
oui alors on fait attention aux siens
droite on lève la tête les poigne de
pied tendu quand on lève les jambes les
doigts tendus quand on sert pas de sa
main droite ou de sa main gauche ou lamé
ou voilà au fath en soit ces échanges
les grandes c'est pas je me débarrasse
du bâton et je dois lancer et elle doit
le rattrape et c'est surtout ça le plus
important
les majorettes ont choisi saga africains
pour le championnat océane 9 ans
explique comment ça se passe après nous
l'avons écouté audition james ou même
pas qu'on aime bien bon gros si c'est
quelqu'un qui aime porte on va échanger
musée parce qu'elle est ou non sans tête
puisque on n'arriverait pas à danser sur
un timbre collector lorinet la petite
soeur d'océane à 6 ans est une des plus
jeunes majorettes et alors ça sert à
quoi de faire ça alors il
ainsi pour nous aujourd'hui pour à
fréquence faut que ça fasse dans la
légende
voilà sans plier les gens et bien à
l'unrwa
pas dans une vie
les félines du cojeul ont déjà un beau
palmarès en particulier la petite océane
ici c'est une coupe que j'ai remporté à
montjaux quand j'étais premier avec une
copine à moi
là c'est tout mais est ce que c'est un
boxeur
c'était quand j'étais première est qu
avec l âge cinq ans et cela fait cinq
ans que la fillette manie le bâton après
lien les devoirs et en tout genre et
encore
après on jette au ballon ce vampire
voilà à la porte la fin alors ça va le
décorer sont disciplinés elle son
enthousiasme de vouloir participer à
tous à toutes ces manifestations à
l'entraînement a commencé à 8 heures au
matin la maison et ça finit très tard le
soir
enfin il ya vraiment une volonté et une
épaule et semant important de leur part
et moi sommes ravis de les voir y avoir
comme c'est aussi bonne mais ça s'est
épuisé en même temps en tant que seul
salaire approche john salley rapproche
énormément adopté dans quatre jours les
fillettes affronteront le public le jury
et leurs concurrentes elles devront
décrocher la meilleure place au
championnat des majorettes